I was raised by a single dad it's just  me and him that was it for the vast  majority of my life Middle Eastern came  here the thousand dollars he was a  doctor came here learned English from  watching television you know what I mean  has the American success story I was  born here all of it was about making him  proud that's what I was trying to do and  then I think that brought my like  adolescence I realized that it was  something that was always going to be  withheld from it so it didn't matter  what it was the goal post would always  move so that he would never be proud  enough right and so like if I got you  know a 99 on a test it wasn't  congratulations that's what you get  wrong so this desire to gain approval  turned into a very deep anger first my  goal was to make as much as my dad and  then it was to make more than my dad and  then it was to make more than my dad had  ever made his whole life Wow and so once  I had done that I wanted the success to  be unquestionable